だからそれを推測してみて
さらに推測能力を働かせちゃうと心が止まることないんだから
死んだら止まると いうことは不可能になっちゃうんですね
自分でわからないんだけど
止まれないはずでしょうと
止まったストップということはないでしょう
世の中で何も ストップというものはありえません
消えるということはありますけど
消えると他の現象が現れるんですね
そこでストップ 全部停止と
ということはないんです
ずっと無限にね 変化していくんですね
そういうわけで 死ぬ瞬間で心はストップ
もう終わったということは言えないでしょうと
それは因果法則には逆らっているんだと
ということで 来世のことを推測できるんですね
証明ではなくてね それで証明します
それになりません 証明じゃないんです
いわば論理的に可能だと
他の選択はないんだと
そう決めるしかね それは推測論ですね
それは仏教でちゃんと使っている推測論です
じゃあ他のことを推測できますか？我々知ってる情報から
実際に知ってる情報から
じゃあ他の推測できますか？消えるということは全然もう体験経験できませんから
消えた 終わったということはね
ですから 今まで経験してきた過去が消えたということはないんだからね
将来的には消えるということはあるんだということは
もうあれ論理的じゃないんで
だから論理的な結論は輪廻あるということなんですね
だからと言って輪廻証明したことにはなりません
それはすごくちゃんと理解しておいてください
輪廻証明したことになりません
いわゆる論理的には輪廻を認めるしか他の選択はできませんということだけ
故に輪廻がありますよとは言えます
そういうわけで 上座仏教の世界とまた他の経量部とか
他の部派の仏教でもこの経量部どうでかわかりませんね
ちょっと いわゆるこの中を否定するんですね
大乗仏教では認めているんですね
大乗仏教というのは もう何者が作ったかとか
バカバカらしいといえば
例えばこのものすごいこういう言葉まで否定するんですよ
ナアガルジュナなんかは
こんなもんも成り立たないんだと
因果法則も成り立たないんだと
我々言うようなこの時間感覚
時間論がありますからね
ルージュの むしろ中論というテキストを読んでみてくれ
時間論という章もあります
そこで全部否定するんです
このこの因縁論も否定するんですけどね
そこまで言いながら平気でなんか認めるんです
あのふうに言う際 だからこの
昔もこの中っていうのは
これはもう屁理屈だということを考えていたんですね
中っていうのはありえないと
いわゆる現象にいわゆる休止というかね
言ってみれば睡眠状態というか
休眠状態があるわけないんだと
輪廻の過程では休眠状態のようなもんですからね
だから逆に休眠状態じゃなくて
逆にしているんですね
この注しているガンダルヴァというやつらには
ものすごい何でも見えるんだと
何でも知ってるんだと
ああだこうだとか それはもう欲界でもなく
色界でもなく 無色界でもなく
自由自在だとかね 言いたい放題のことを言うんですね
だからこの根拠なしに喋るともう何でも喋られますからね
根拠なしに物事を考えるのはものすごいバカバカしいんですね
だから余計なことを考えない方が一番いいんです
考えるということは 決して真理に至る道じゃないんです
だから少なく少なく考える人はすごく真理に近いんですね
だから時間かからないで
逆にもう瞬時に考える人にとっては一番真理に近い物事を考えると思うんですね
瞬時にその瞬時のことを考える
とにかくこの余計に考えちゃうといろんなことを考えしまうだけのことで
とにかくあの まあ初期仏教では中とかとか
そういう概念は全くなかったんですけど
後で生まれてきたし いろんな部派仏教の中でね
そういうのは側的に考えて作ったものだと思いますけどね
例えば人が死んだからね
すぐ瞬間に次の生を決められますかと
まあそう考えただろうと思いますけどね
だからほんのちょっと待って考えて
どっちにしようかなと
次の転生はじゃああっちにしますか
そういうふうな このまあ本当は根拠すごいくだらない
もうもう根拠から生まれるものなんで
我々今ありがたがっているだけの
まあそれにはそれなりの原因があって
やっぱり我々人間にしたっても
何かすぐ決めるのはなかなか難しいんですね
どんなレストランに行って何食べようかなとかね
メニュー見ながらこれも美味しいし
これもじゃあどっちにしようかなとかね
そういうふうに人間にとってはこの選択がいくつかあると
まあちょっと決めにくいという心の働きがあります
それを見て言ってるということもあります
でも だからといって実際物事は客観的に見ると
実際に物事はどのように起きているかというと
間隔がなしに起きてるんです
あの時間を間を無視して考えちゃうと
因果法則を無視して考えちゃうと
間隔の概念が生まれるんですね
例えばレストランに行ってメニューを取って決めると
決める間には 10分かかったならば
10分間彷徨ったことになっちゃうんですね
心が それはこの決まったという現象とメニューをメニューを取ったという現象 2つだけ繋げると
時間の間が生まれるんであって
それは因果法則を無視しているんです
その心には間隔があったわけじゃないんです
メニューを取る 1番目の料理のことを見る
次のことを見ると 内容はどうですかと見ると
味はどういうでしょうか
どういう味でしょうかと想像してみるとか
今日昼ご飯が何食べたかとまた思い出してみるとかね
そういうふうなことで
じゃあ次の料理に行きましょうと
じゃあこれに行きましょうと
でも そういうふうに心は止まることなくきちんと働いてるんですね
だから間隔なく働いてはいるんです
だからここは時間 その経過したものは無視して
取っちゃうとレストランに
メニューを-- メニューを取った決-- 決めたっていうことだけ見ると
もう時間かかってる あの
この生まれ変わったことを思い出している人々もいます
そういうケースは あの
まあ日本ではそういう研究やりませんからね
で やるところもありますね
それやるところでちゃんとこの実際にこの人が自分の過去をね
まあ思い出すと で その人間の場合だけ研究できますからね
過去でどこかで死んだと
そちらの親の名前とかね
自分の前の名前とか 結婚した相手の名前とかね
家のこととか思い出しているならば
思い出す場合は実際にそういうことがあったかということを調べることできますね
それで あの ちゃんと調べたら
その人が言っていることは全くぴったしその通りだとわかる場合はね
まあ一応その何何さんがここであの
生まれ変わったっていうことには言えるんですね
大体子供はまあ小さい時は時々思い出して言ったりする場合あります
で 日本の子供でも言う可能性ありますけどね
もう我々の頭の中そういう概念ないんだから
あんたなんでバカなこと言ってるんですかと
それだけで終わっちゃいます
バカなこと言ってるんだというふうに否定されちゃったら
子供はまたそこを気をつけるんですね
子供が言ってるもう全くちんぷんかんぷんの言葉には何か訳があるんです
小さい時はすごい我々驚くで
すごい想像力だ あれだこれだとかね
で ほとんど自分の過去の経験やらいろんなことやらね
言うんだけど 我々理解できない
この繋がりがわかりません
なんでそんなこと言うの？バカなこと言うなと
で 抑えちゃう それだけで子供はもうすごく何て言いますか
がっかりしてね そういうことを考えないようにしちゃうんですね
バカでないことは大人が考えてるんだからその通りに考える
それで思い出せなくなっちゃうんです
そういうあの 実際に研究しているケースの中見ても
だから子供が生まれて喋り始めたら過去のことを喋ると
そこで逆に時間計算してみるんですね
だからもう一応分かりますからね
まあ妊娠はこれぐらい時間取るんだと
それで今と逆算で それ前の人がいつ死んだかっていうこと
ちゃんと記録ありますからね
その死んだ日で その瞬間でこちらで妊娠したという計算はほとんど合わないんです
例えば十-- 十二月三十一日で死んだならば
こちらで十月あたりで生まれなくちゃいけないんですね
人が 生まれ変わったならば
で そのぴったし十月で生まれたっていうことにならないんです
あるいは一年の間隔とか
三年の間隔とか 半年の間隔とか出てくるんです
ですから このそこでまた
あ やっぱり間があった
その間はその人に聞いてもわからない
それでまた宙の概念が生まれてきちゃうんですね
そういう研究スリランカでやってますから
いろんな人々の間で やっぱり宙を否定するべきじゃないんだと思ってる人もいるんです
最近亡くなった あのすごい年取って亡くなったスリランカの有名なお坊様 NHK
でもあのなんとかブッダの番組で最後に出たんですけど
そういうもうバカな考え方いっぱい持っていたんです
すごい学者ですけどね
で まあ学者だけで まあ言ってることはもうアホなことを結構言っていたんです
そのお坊さんもやっぱり宙はまあ否定するべきじゃないんだ
それは自分がいろんなマハダイジョウテキストもかなじの学者だからね
ものすごく読んでいるし
だからダイノウジョウのテキストっていうのは
まあいろいろまあ編集したり作ったり書いたりもしましたから
だからそこら辺のものやら
いろんなものを対照しながら
まあもう学問的にいろんなことを言うだけであって
やっぱり実際に因果法則ということは
こんなこの学問的に見るんじゃなくて
科学的に実験しながら見てみると
宙っていうのはありえないっていうことがわかるはずなんですね
間がないんだと そこで時間の
例えば一年経ってから生まれ変わったとしたっても
一年間その人は休-- 休-- 休眠状態にいたっていうわけにはならないんです
他の形で心はやっぱりちゃんと変化していたんだからね
[笑い]それはなぜ条件で取りますかとね
感覚がないっていうこと
無感因になるかというと
やっぱり例えば人が聞くと
例えばこの電子が蛍光灯に当たる
蛍光灯に塗ってる薬に当たると当たると光る
まあそれわかりますと
なぜ電子が蛍光灯に当たったら光りますか？ということは
なんかどうかちょっと説明しにくいところもありますね
例えば米を炊いたらご飯になる
なぜですか？米と炊くという条件が揃ったら
もうやっぱりご飯になりますね
ご飯は結果で 米は原因で
なぜなるんですかね 説明できないでしょうに
どんなものでもやっぱり因果法則は事実なんですけど
全部説明できるということでもまだなってないんですね
だからどんなものでも同じこと
例えばブドウを食べたと
美味しかったと なぜですかね
だからそちらに説明はないんです
もう甘かったんだから美味しかった
あんた甘かったんだからと美味しかったわけじゃん
あんたブドウが好きだから美味しかった
なぜ好きだから美味しいんですかと聞けばいいでしょうに
ブドウは好きだから美味しかったと
で 何でしょうかね なぜ好きだったら美味しいですかね
だから原因関係が原因結果関係はしっかりしているんです
ブドウ好きな人はもうブドウを食べたら美味しいと感じる
その同じ人がキウイは嫌だったら食べたら美味しくないと感じるし
それはもう決まってるんです
だから人の好みは美味しく美味しくないかという判断決めるんだ
それもはっきりしているんです
人の好みとしては ブドウを好むんだったら
ブドウを食べたら美味しく感じるんです
だから好みも原因になるんですね
でもなぜですか だから説明できないでしょ
そういうふうに因果法則の流れをかなりもういろいろあります
説明は及ばないところ
何でも説明 で解説よってなっても
ノリですね まあですから
このなぜという説明できない場合は
一つの切り札にはもうこの感覚論を使うんです
例えば美味しい 好きなものには美味しいという結果が生まれるのは
経験上情報を集めたらまあ決まってる結果なんですね
それも決まってる結果です
ですから 決まってる結果が生まれるんですけど
やっぱり決まってる結果は感覚なしにもう一つの現象を消えると
次の現象はどうしても現れなくちゃいけないんです
どうしても現れなくちゃいけないんです
ですから ブドウを食べてみたら
どうしても美味しいという感覚は現れざるを得ない
感覚がないんだからということになるわけです
あまりいい例とは説明はあまり合わないんだけど
なぜこの原因でこの結果が生まれるかという場合は
お釈迦様は原因消えたら消えるんだから
その原因でこの結果が生まれるんだというふうな
すごいわかりやすい合理的なところで終わっちゃいましたけどね
お釈迦様はすごく大胆に説法するんだからね
これは原因で これは結果ですよと
なんでこれ原因聞いちゃったら結果消えるんだから
だからこれは原因だと
そこで終わっちゃうんです
で 原因があると結果が感覚なしに現れるんだ
だから結果が生まれることを避けられないんですね
原因があったらもう確実に結果が現れる
それはもうどうしようもない
もう避けられない というわけで
無間ということは条件にしているんです
だから見つめると別にいらない条件ですけどね
じゃあ難しくなりますから
さっさと終わりまで説明します
次にはサマナンタラというパッチェラですね
日本語で極極無間無間と書いてますけど
その言葉と引っかからない方がいいんです
このサマナンタラというのはサマという言葉ありますけど
アビダマでははっきりとこう言うんです
アナンタラパッチェイコールサマナンタラパッチェ
全くイコールなんです
イコールだから 1つ消してくださいと言いたいんだけどね
なんでブッダがそうしてるかさっぱりわからないんです
で もしかすると これは
これ私の個人的な考え方なんですけど
これはサマーナサマナンタラということが
まあサマナンタラになったんじゃないかなと
思いますけど で これ私の説明する前に
普通の説明しておきます
で アナンタラっていうのは感覚がないという
サマナンタラっていうのはまたサマサンという
まあよくも感覚なく生まれるという
まあ同じ意味で取ってるんですね
ですからダブってるんだから
1つは綺麗に取り消せる
そういう風にこのほんのちょっとプリフィックスつけるんだけど
別にだからといって意味がそんなに大胆に変わるわけでもない場合もありますね
サマという言葉は同じことですね
じゃあこれサマーナになっちゃうとどういう風になるかというと
かなり意味が変わるんです
だからそれ言うべきかどうか私もわかりませんだけど
サマーナっていうのはイコールという同等というか
同じという意味なんですね
だから同じ感覚と いう意味になっちゃうんです
いわゆる感覚で言えば感覚ないということなんですけど
そちらへんに同じという言葉を入れてみれば
それでもイコールであることはイコールになりますけど
上と下が それはこの一つの現象が現れて
次の現象消えて 次の現象が現れるでしょうに
そこは無限的に生まれますけど
それはいつでもイコールだと
無限的な状態ももう変わらないと
もし感覚がある場合も
その感覚もまた全く同じだよと
感覚は必要な場合も 例えば歩くことにしたっても時間取りますから
同時かないかと 同時と言ったら間違っているし
左足上げるも下ろすことで右足に上がることっていうのは同時だと思ったらありえないし
でも時間も取るんだから
なんか言葉では言いにくいんだけど
時間は取っている だから最終的には時間取っているんだから
それだったらこの無間なんですけど
そちらにはいつでもイコールの同じの感覚
隔たりが 隔たりが感覚がないということはいつでも似ているんだとというややこしいところになりますけどね
そんなに難しいことでもないんです
まあとにかく皆様方は上と下が同じだと理解しておけばね
感覚がないという意味なんです
とにかくそれだけで十分です
次は次にサハジャーテ
サハジャーテ・パッティ
サハっていうのは一緒に
ジャータっていうのは生まれると現れるということも条件になるんだと
それは説明しちゃうとすごく難しくなりますから
こういう風に理解してください
例えば我々には怒りがありますね
よくわかる わかりやすいことですね
怒りが生まれる 怒ったりする
で 怒りというのは心性ですからね
心が働いていて その心の中に怒りが起きたり
欲が起きたり 混乱が起きたり
いろんなものが起きたりする
でも心も生滅変化していくんですね
そこで怒りが生まれるためには
心も一緒に生まれなくちゃいけないんですね
だから心が現れると一緒に怒りも現れたということなんですね
だから一緒に生まれるということを言っているんです
サハジャータというのは一緒に現れるということ
もっとわかりやすい例っていうのはありますかね
で 物質の世界ではね これいろいろあるでしょうと思いますけど
なかなか浮かばないね
で  何かまあ 例えばアイスクリームありますね
アイスクリームというのは何か液体を固めたものなんですね
まあ凍らせて凍らせたものなんですけど
で 液体は凍らせた 飲めるジュースとかなんとかとは凍らせただけでアイスクリームになるわけじゃないんです
アイスクリームというのは
やっぱりこの凍らす過程でかき混ぜてかき混ぜて空気を入れるんですね
そこで凍った分子の間にいっぱい空気が入ってるんですね
そこで柔らかいアイスクリームというものが出てくるでしょ
ソフトクリームとかね
で そのソフトクリームの場合は
もうソフトのアイスクリームの場合は
それをもう空気をとってみたら
取るためには溶かす ちょっと溶かしてもらう
まあ液体になってくると中に入ってる空気が逃げてしまうでしょ
それでまた凍らせてみたらどうですかね
全然元のアイスクリームに戻らないでしょうに
ただまあアイスになってしまっちゃうんですね
アイスクリームの場合は溶けやすく
いろいろものを入れているんだからね
実験しやすいんです 普通のアイスクリームを持っていて
外部屋に置いておけば
どんどんどんどん溶けて液体になる
液体になったらまた冷凍庫に入れてみれば元に戻るかというと
元に戻りません 固めるんですけど
で ですから アイスクリームという場合は
いつでも一緒にその間に空気がある必要がありますね
だから一緒にいるということはどうしても必要なんです
だからあんまりそれも厳密に考えるとそんなにいい例ではないんだけど
物質の世界で まあやっぱり
まあ他の例があるかもしれませんが
あまり私には思い浮かびませんだけどね
で 水を持ってきてくださいと言ったら
どうしても容器は必要でしょう
何か入れ物が必要 だから一緒でないと成り立たないんです
手で持ってきた手はやっぱり器になっちゃいますから
水だけ純粋に持ってくることはできません
だから水を運ぶという場合は
やっぱり容器も運ぶということをしなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうふうに このある現象については
他の現象も一緒にいる必要があります
ガラスと水を入れて持ってきても
そこに水があるということは
あくまでもガラスが元気でいる時だけなんで
ガラスが割れちゃうと水もなくなってしまっちゃうんです
でもその例はサハジャータ・パッチーにはなりません
なぜならば ガラスがあって水をなくすということはできますから
飲んでしまえばガラスが残って水が消えるでしょう
ですからサハジャータ・パッチーにはなりません
だからいい例ではないんです
一応 水を運ぶぐらいの部分では理解できます
運ぶならば 入れ物はどうしても必要です
その場合は 2つ離れることはできません
サハジャータ・パッチーの場合はいつでも一緒にいなきゃいけないんですね
だから一つ取っちゃうと
もう一つも消えてしまう
それぐらい厳密に一緒なんです
で 人間の体から言うとわかりやすいのはこの水ですね
ご飯食べても何食べても
いつでも水と一緒でなければ
どうしようもないです
例えばビタミンやら色々化学成分必要だよと
その化学成分だけ体に入れることは不可能なんです
いつでも水が必要です
血液の中では水がありますからね
細胞の中では水がありますから
水に溶けていないと もう永久的に我々の体の中でね
何も受け入れることはできません
まあ脂肪とかありますけど
脂肪は使いませんだから体が
それもまた分解して水に溶かしてから使うんですね
ですから体の例で言えば
もういつでも水と一緒ということは必要ですね
水がなくなったらもう大変なことになります
例えば我々が食べるご飯の中にたくさん水分
水分が入っているでしょうし
その水を取ったら食べられないので石みたいに硬くなっちゃいますからね
ご飯も こしてみれば石みたいに硬いんですね
じゃあそれでも食べられると思って口に入れるでしょう
口に入れて歯がありますから
歯で噛みますよ 噛んだところで食べられますから
その場合どうなるかというと
やっぱり水で溶けるんでしょう
溶けてからはもう体の中に入っちゃう
じゃあ噛まないで あの硬くなった米をご飯を
あのご飯を硬くしたらもう米より硬いんです
米は簡単に噛めますけど
ご飯なんか天日に干したりすると米よりはすっごい硬いんです
じゃあそのまま飲み込んだとする
それでももしお腹の中で消化したというならば
やっぱり溶けてるはずなんです
溶けなかった中で そのまま体から出ていくだけ
ですから やっぱり体に成分入るということは
確実に水に溶けているかないかということで決めます
まあそういうふうな感じで
世の中でやっぱりこの因果法則の中で一緒にいるということを条件になる場合あります
そういう条件もありますよ
それ条件ですね 一緒にいるという条件
一緒に現れるという条件
で 因果法則の中ではこれをどこで使ってますかというと
やっぱり心の心素の場合はね
怒りであろうか 五十二種類の心処がありますから
怒りやら貪りやらいろいろなものがありますね
そういうのはやっぱりいつでも五十二も一緒に生まれませんだからもう正反対なこといっぱいありますからね
やっぱり心があって心素がある
心素と心は決して引き離すことはできません
次はアナンャ アンニャマンニャパッチェというんですね
アンニャマンニャパッチェというのは
これはもう日本語で書いてる意味でいいんですね
相互 互いに影響し合うということで相互因ですね
まあそれはまあ三脚と同じく
なぜ三脚が立ってるかというと
やっぱり三脚の三つの足が互いに助け合ってるんです
一つでも取ったら倒れるんです
で 体の場合もわかりやすいし
心が体を支えているんですね
心がなかったら体がないんです
もう腐って消えてしまうんです
そこで体があるんだから心が支えられてるんです
互いに助け合っているんですね
そこで続けているんですね
アンニャマンニャの次は
ニッセ 次の二つはニッセパッチェ
ウパニッセパッチェと言うんです
それはニッセパッチェもウパニッセパッチェも全く同じなんです
ただ言葉だけ違う だからそんなに条件喋るんだったらまた繰り返す必要はないんです
ですからこれ一つなんですね
えーと  [笑い]